so first of all let me start by saying
congrats on the movie I had a blast
watching this thing I have a million
questions for both of you but since I
have a little extra time I need to drill
down on Hugh for a quick second urine to
master two of my favorite movies of the
last few years and I've told one of this
to you is Cloud Atlas in Paddington - I
think both of those are very similar
films very similar but they're both
masterpieces so nice to say that I've
warmed to you I am curious though well
to what what do you remember about both
of those films did you realise when you
were making Bo that they were gonna be
these classics of cinema for me it's not
clearly not but I I was aware that both
directors double Chomsky's and Paul King
and Paddington were very very filmy and
I for me that's the thing you want it's
not like Guy Ritchie there's quite a
difference between people who do TV or
what you might call blown up TV and
people who are really steeped marinated
in the history of cinema
you know I coursezi for instance or
Tarantino and and Paul King and the
Wachowskis come into that category
everything is kind of a reference or on
omage and it really shows in filmmaking
I think and you look at Paddington -
it's full of or Martius - all kinds of
films Charlie Chaplin films and so on
and you know there were Cheska's you
can't get more cinematic than them
we even shot it on film do you remember
film I'm familiar I've heard about it
yeah some process and I laughs yeah
right Oh choking me - I get to talk to
the two of you guys today you both
worked with guy before and then I'm
curious what was has he changed at all
or is he still the guy that you met that
first time you worked with him yeah I
mean I think his his process is pretty
consistent and it's eccentric wonderful
and consistency you know he you know I
think we've said it before we've both
said it a lot today but he really keeps
you on your toes guy this you know
there's a lot of leeway to play around
and two tries
stuff you know to have a sense of real
ownership over the role but then it he's
also very specific in making sure that
whatever that is you know goes through
the the Ricci filter and you know he can
days can go just wonderfully sort of on
script and you know and and there's a
real celebration of what we're doing and
then some days it can feel the same to
the actor but to guy everything's going
wrong and the script is [ __ ] in York
[ __ ] and everything needs to be
completely reimagined and on those days
it can be quite challenging but you know
what keeps you honest you know and it
challenges me in a way that's exciting
because you can't just show up and go
through a process of executing your
intention you have to like work in real
time and guy is fantastic in real time I
mean he can just write scenes and
completely reimagine something that
really works just you know in the in the
drop of a hat so it's kind of exciting
kind of frustrating at times yes it's
like a guy when he's I've noticed with
some very good directors like Stephen
Frears
similar in a way they don't come with a
very strong preconceived notion of how a
scene or even a film might be they come
ready to be entertained ready to see it
on the monitor they've got to see it on
a screen and then they know what they've
got it might be something that they love
big tick thank you you know check the
gate or it might be which doesn't work
at all let's rican sieve it but they
don't know it until they've seen it and
that what what that means is that it has
to be created fresh on the day and
that's what the camera likes it likes
fresh on the day if it's a recording of
a pre rehearsed thing that camera gets
bored I what I like about this is that
everyone looks like they stepped out of
GQ you know all the costumes talked a
little bit about like that has to be fun
going clothes shopping or have it
working with wardrobe to dress or
character yeah it's fantastic I mean
I've never I don't think ever felt as
suave or felt as confident in a car
and I costume as they did on this guy it
was definitely you know on both the
films I did with guy I said we spent
more time discussing costume than any
other element in the preparation period
he actually took me shopping on this
film we went to a few of his favorite
clothing stores and you know bought
suits and shirts and you know it's quite
lovely way to spend an afternoon you
know had a couple of wines and went
shopping did you get to do this we went
shopping but it was for food it was just
didn't grocery shopping uh one of the
things that also about a guy is that I
guess he does this thing called black
box rehearsals yeah before you start
shooting could you sort of own that and
what that process is like well I think
it was it pertains to what I was saying
earlier about not having a preconceived
idea it doesn't go by script very much
it had he has to see it on a screen so
instead of doing a normal read through
where you listen and maybe read the
script with with the width of cast he's
reading it he films it films the whole
film in one day again sort of black
curtains edits it together so then he
can see it he knows what he's got yeah
I'm very Hardy process do one two very
rarely three takes you know a couple of
cameras a couple of different pieces of
coverage but you know you'll read the
scene through all together you know
standing in sort of you know rough
approximation of some costume with a
couple of props around reading suspense
often teleprompter
yes that's we shoot the entire film and
it's in its most naked form and then he
edits it fully edits it watches it and
uses that as a guy to do his final pass
on the script before we actually go in
start shooting that's so it's that's
that's yeah I've never heard anyone do
that but that also I would imagine that
helps see what you have you know yeah I
said maybe a bit like how animators work
you know when they do is sort of very
rough black-and-white sketch version
before they get to the expensive stuff
often when everyone's talking about a
film like this they're mentioning guy
they're mentioning the cast what we're
trying to do on Collider recently is
about like an unsung hero so someone
that maybe should get some credit for
working on this or was a you know key
part of the film but maybe no one thinks
to mention you know what I mean bet
there'd be a first ad whether it be
someone else is there someone that you
want to sort of shine a light on well
you know the editor didn't you yeah I
know Jimbo the editor mm-hmm who I think
has had a very acute effect on the
overall Guy Ritchie style of filmmaking
you know he I think the the aspiration
initially with this with guy was to sort
of make a much more classic style of
filmmaking you know it wasn't gonna do
like the snap cuts and the whips and all
of those type of things that have sort
of become trademark and I think they got
in and Jimbo starts working his magic on
it and guy just finds it irresistible
you know I think Jim has a huge part of
the overall Guy Ritchie machinery and
then I would say guy's assistant for
many many years who's sort of much more
I mean well you know a director's
assistant often works very very closely
and creatively with the director I found
but they've been working for many many
years and and Ivan sort of shepherded
this project and ended up becoming a
full producer on it so I know he worked
very very hard and for many years to
bring this to fruition so you guys have
some great scenes together a lot of
scenes together that's my last question
what it's what surprised you about each
other that maybe you weren't expecting
learning you know spending so much time
together if anything as actors you mean
oh yeah or as people oh well I can see I
was surprised by how cool charli's
there's a natural natural corner I know
whether that's you or pharmaceuticals
he's he's cool he's laid-back and I'm
not at all I'm wound up like a with it
was I was surprised by that and as for
his secret I mean I I know them all
and we did I mean we actually didn't
spend that much time together was about
four and a half days I think total which
really isn't extraordinary I think when
you see the end result which I haven't
but I can imagine because Hugh delivers
somewhere in the region of forty five
pages of monologue but yeah we that was
all shot in about four and a half days I
think I'm stunned by that here
remarkable right
stunned yeah I have no idea he brought
the Thunder as they say this piece is
like mmm that is roughly true